What's up guys, Helen here today. I want to talk about that weird feeling.
I get in the pit of my stomach when Hulu feeds me.
An ad like this bullying the me too movement against sexual harassment
validity. That's right advertising, but make it work.
Woke advertising has become an increasingly omnipresent phenomenon in our media
landscape. It's not enough to sell a hamburger.
He got a sell a mental health revolution.
Now I'm not saying I prefer the gross advertisements of yesteryear or even
any ads at all. However, if you're cynical like us,
you probably feel a little weird about your bath soap being imbued with
progressive new ideas about womanhood in the interest of maintaining a healthy
skepticism toward anyone who's ultimately trying to sell me more stuff I've been
wondering.
Why does every advertisement lately seem to come furnished with the political
message? And what does it mean for us?
Welcome to this wisecrack edition on how advertising got woke and
Hey, if you hate ads, Loker otherwise,
there's a way you can watch wisecrack videos without any brand asking you to do
anything by becoming a patron, you can watch all of our content ad free.
It also helps us keep making great in depth content like this video,
whether or not it's at friendly checkout, patrion.com/wisecrack,
or click right here to learn more.
We have to start by asking what exactly is a woke ad.
Is it the SpaghettiOs tweets about Pearl Harbor or is it more like when I Kia
decides to feature a gay couple back in 1994?
Or is it when Nike pays Colin Kaepernick to be a spokesperson precisely because
of his activism,
we'd argue that woke advertising is defined by its invocation of social causes
and social movements of a given moment,
especially those affiliated with progress and social change. So, sorry,
SpaghettiOs. We are not woke. That's not to say conservative brands.
Don't also try to capitalize on the politics of their consumers,
but nobody would call that one. Especially these days,
woke ads typically focus on identity based issues surrounding race, gender,
sexuality, disabilities, and so forth. In this way.
The Kendall Jenner Pepsi ad is woke because it intended to align itself with
black lives matter. It just failed hilariously. Under this definition,
the secret deodorant ad in the 1970s,
strong enough for a man made for a woman was probably somewhat woke for the
feminist movement at the time, but the same ethos in a Covergirl ad in 2020,
probably not.
There's also the question of whether say showing a female executive in an ad is
some woke affirmation of girl bosses, or just,
you know what professional life is like today.
Now a lot of you might be screaming.
All advertising is self-interested your big dumb,
dumb companies are just trying to sell stuff to as many people as possible,
regardless of skin color, sexual orientation or gender.
They're just getting with the times and targeting their accordingly.
Whether that's two dudes putting their relationship through the gauntlet of
building Ikea furniture together,
or just this guy who needs an energy drink for gamers or whoever needs this pink
gamer chair, but economic reasons aside.
What if it's just really bad versus advertisements like any form of
visual or literary? Very storytelling have always been latent with values.
There are reflections of our culture.
And if our culture wants you to move to the burbs and raise a family,
that's what they're going to reflect.
Or if society wants you to get rich and hot add laws and reflect that,
but as values change ads naturally do too,
as a result and contrary to popular belief, well,
advertising is not at all a new phenomenon. It's pretty old.
Historically most woke advertising appeal to women overwhelmingly white by
reflecting various stages of the feminist movement.
As explained by Andy's Eisler author of we were feminist once in the late 19th
and early 20th century,
when some younger women were feeling stifled by Victorian notions of idealized
womanhood,
advertisers piggybacked off the existing feminist notion of the emancipated new
woman by frequently depicting young,
independent gals who bucked against Victoria norms and even served on juries.
The new woman was according to his, Eisler essentially a watered down,
more palatable suffragette who surprise like buying things,
this conflict between the advertiser friendly new woman and the ruckus raising
hunger striking suffragette is at the heart of the problem with woke
advertising.
And it is maybe best illustrated by the torches of freedom campaign,
which very publicly debut during a parade in 1929,
it was masterminded by one Edward Bernays,
the creator of modern public relations and Sigmund Freud's nephew.
Bernays believed that people bought things not based on what they needed,
but based on the feelings, a given commodity inspired.
So he organized a stunt to sell cigarettes to women who were typically looked
down upon it. They smoked outside of their homes.
He paid a group of debutantes to light up during new York's Easter day parade
and made sure the event was both captured by the press and interpreted as a
protest for women's rights. Cigarettes were no longer desperate men.
They were torches of freedom, symbolizing female emancipation fittingly.
The cigarette industry would adapt its ads for the next phase of women's
movement. 40 years later when Virginia Slims told women,
you have come a long way baby, as they sold them,
cancer sticks that 1968 tagline was in itself a response to a growing
threat for advertisers,
feminist no longer interested in traditional beauty standards, housework,
and so on might end up buying less lipstick and Clorox.
So some savvy brands like Charlie perfume made like advertisers of
yore and incorporated elements of the feminist movement depicting a liberated
bold woman who held down a job and look good while doing it without explicitly
using controversial feminist language. In all of these examples,
we can see one of the first dangers of woke.
It dilutes the political message of a movement,
women who were literally not allowed to apply for a credit card without a male
under signer were asked to redirect their attention to buying the feminist
perfume or the emancipatory cigarette. Why March at all,
when you can consume fittingly,
a similar phenomenon happened to black Americans before the civil rights
movement and the rise of the black middle-class in the 1950s advertising to
people of color was virtually non-existent. Advertisers had simply,
always targeted white Americans viewed in that framework.
Mainstream ads showing black people at all was at face value,
sadly kind of progressive some of the first companies to even advertise in black
run newspapers were you guessed it cigarette companies.
The reason they did it is pretty instructive internal humans for tobacco company
Brown and Williamson report that in the case of black Spanic communities,
the relatively small and often tightly knit minority community can work to be in
W's marketing advantage if exploited properly.
And just like with the feminist movement,
as the burgeoning civil rights movement made headway as began,
co-opting imagery associated with black power,
none more bluntly than this 1970 JC penny ad that reads SLAC power as
historian Stewart. Eowyn put it at the time.
The advertising industry seeking markets has generated a mass culture,
which reflects the spirits, but not the cutting edge of this resistance.
But by the 1980s,
our contemporary brand of woke advertising was really coming into its own.
Again,
aimed primarily at white women in what [inaudible] calls empower timesing.
This was a time when consumer choices exploded and consumption became
elevated as a measure of liberation as cultural historian and media critic,
Susan J.
Douglas put it elite is a men narcissism merged in a perfect appeal to forget
the political already and get back to the personal,
which you might be able to do something about specifically by buying those
designer eyeglasses, you could change your small corner of the world.
Ads would continue to capitalize off of feminist critiques of mass consumer
culture as seen in this Nike ad campaign in the early nineties.
What's so interesting about this ad is the way it specifically invokes the pain
of women living in a world that judges them overwhelmingly by their appearance,
rather than being judged by curves.
It reads a woman should be judged by who she is and who she is trying to become.
This leads to another serious problem with woke advertising.
If all advertising sells dreams,
woke ads tend to sell the dream of respect and equality,
reading this ad stirs real emotions,
literally making Oprah cry on air ad, sell solutions,
whether it's for your leaky, whatever, or your untoned arms.
The solution Nike is selling in this case is the solution to sexism.
You're not buying a running shoe made in a sweat shop.
You're buying good quality and respect the guiding principle shopping,
but make it feminist.
It's also worth noting that the feminism of Nike was anything,
but as a coalition of women's groups said at the time,
while the women who wear Nike shoes in the United States are encouraged to
perform their personal best. The Indonesian,
Vietnamese and Chinese women making the shoes often suffer from inadequate
wages, corporal punishment,
forced overtime and or sexual harassment women.
Weren't the only group being targeted by woke advertising at the turn of the
century though,
the aforementioned Ikea ad was only the first of many active campaigns by
corporations to court.
So-called dollars as author Alexandra Chasen explains in her book,
selling out such courting of the market was said to signal an end to
homophobia.
This can most visibly be seen in the rise of everything rainbow in recent
decades, an effective co-opting of the rainbow flag designed by gay activists,
Gilbert Baker in the late seventies,
everything from rainbow underwear to rainbow Instagram images to rainbow
Chipotle burritos,
proport to celebrate queerness while really elevating the simple act of buying
walk is, and always will be extra as Jason puts it.
When describing rainbow clothes,
the reduction of politics to style implies that consumption can amount to
political change attempts to imbue advertising with woke messaging became
increasingly more explicit throughout the two thousands best exemplified by the
ubiquity of this is what a feminist looks like, shirts,
which literalize the notion that buying the right thing signals your commitment
to the cause of women's rights. And in the past five years,
as feminism has become increasingly less taboo advertising that co-ops feminist
language has become all, but ubiquitous, that's not surprising.
Woke advertising generally supports the status quo with risk averse
corporations,
typically choosing to piggyback off of existing social change rather than
furthering it in this lens. It's no surprise that Beyonce is 2014.
Feminist VMAX moment was followed by an explosion of brands,
evoking feminism, queen bean made it safe and advertising followed.
What's really interesting about these ads is that they have nothing to do with
the product and everything to do with exploring the pain and oppression,
women and girls face dubbed,
hashtag [inaudible] for their purportedly feminist messaging.
These ads almost guaranteed to tug at the heartstrings.
This is already a reason to be wary. Remember Edward Bernays,
it's not about the product. It's about the way the product makes you feel.
And if these sanitary napkins make you feel sad for the way your twelve-year-old
self was pigeonholed,
you're more likely to buy them perhaps after seeing the rampant success of
[inaudible] corporations have in recent years become to explicitly draw on black
activism for inspiration,
a Procter and gamble ad from 2017 show several black parents talking to their
children about the racism they will inevitably encounter.
It concludes by imagining a world where such conversations are not necessary as
with women's ads.
These ads draw on real pain while offering wish fulfillment by imagining a lest
racist future sound, a little manipulative,
never is this more apparent than in that widely panned Pepsi ad in which Kendall
Jenner dissolves tensions between the police and protestors with a can of soda.
Ironically, this ad functions like a much less subtle version of 1970 ones.
I'd like to buy the world of Coke, Erin,
in the midst of the Vietnam war and massive social upheaval.
It simply implied that if everyone chilled out with a carbonated beverage Wars
and stuff wouldn't happen.
[Inaudible].
It went on to receive countless accolades, inspired fan mail,
and as a song, even charted in several countries.
But the Jenner Pepsi ad somehow crossed a threshold of believability by making
all too obvious.
The implication that a Pepsi could end racism on the other hand,
brands are also eager to exploit the credibility earned by activists to steal
more stuff.
Advertisers today are dealing with similar issues that they faced from social
issues of the last century, but maybe a little more.
So millennial and gen Z consumers overwhelmingly say that they prefer to buy
from brands that share their values or have a higher purpose. That is,
we want to know that our coffee is helping some farmer in Nicaragua,
send their kids to school or that our beans do or don't support the right
presidential candidate. But there's another force pushing this change today.
Products are increasingly disappearing from advertisements,
which instead promote the more nebulous brand scholar.
Nikki Lisa Cole ties this transformation to the increased outsourcing of
production.
Leaving corporations progressively more detached from the actual products they
made as Cole puts it.
Companies used to stand on a product that was your name, the product you made,
but when you don't actually make the product,
you have to come up with something else to sell to people.
That thing of course is a brand. And in many cases,
a hashtag woke brand as a result,
brands are doing another new thing.
Something we've mentioned in previous videos, they're becoming people,
woke people. The rise of social media has enabled a host of new,
usually painful ways for brands to interact with potential consumers and
interact. They do, especially if it means making themselves look,
noble brands increasingly are placing themselves at the center of flashpoint
cultural issues.
A Bloomberg analysis found that within three weeks of the murder of George
Floyd,
76 of the world's top 100 brands had posted at least one corporate statement
about racial justice.
In this Instagram post FISA managed to incorporate two phrases iconic to its
advertising,
turning it slogan everywhere you want to be into where we want to be and
slightly including part of their messaging excepted everywhere. Meanwhile,
Zahra,
the fast fashion company made infamous in 2016 for profiting of child labor
posted a black square that mostly yielded inpatient comments from customers
complaining about late shipping.
This queasy moment encapsulates the uneasy relationship between commerce and
social justice.
While some saw the quote unquote blackout as great for PR many criticized it as
co-opting a campaign conceived by black musicians and activists who were drowned
out amid a sea of corporate sponsored and performative black squares.
When the CEO of JP Morgan chase took a knee to invoke Colin Kaepernick diversity
consultant,
why Von Hutchinson responded by telling the Washington post that there's a lot
of performative allyship going round. Nobody's asking for a CEO to take a knee.
You take the knee after you change your policies. And of course,
as with feminism,
it's not a coincidence that this outpouring of corporate support comes at a time
when calls and support for ending police brutality is at an all-time high.
In other words, those support black lives matter when it's least controversial,
most convenient and financially safe to do so,
which is why I want to tell you right here.
And now that wisecrack is committed to ensuring all women can apply for and use
credit cards without male supervision.
And you can take a stand right now with us by taking your credit card and using
it to become a patron.
Not only will you send a strong message to sexist credit card companies,
but you'll get ad free and early access to all of our videos plus higher levels.
Get you access to cool stuff like the wisecrack discord,
where you can hang out with wisecrack staff and fans,
be sure to let everyone know in there how much you support my right to
incessantly order takeout. Even when I have a fully stocked fridge,
check it out and make us stand by going to patrion.com/wisecrack and
as always, thanks for watching peace.
[Inaudible].